[Music]
no you're both single yeah
do you guys know each other we just met
you just met oh well here we are we
don't know each other i know this is the
first time i'm kind of nervous right
names i'm gonna play a little dating
game for the drew barrymore show let's
do it
i'm elizabeth i'm 28 and i'm an ad
specialist i'm chris i'm kind of a nerd
so i do like av audio visual photography
and i work for the united nations
so i'm michael hi nice to meet you hi
sebastian
and uh what do you do for work semester
i'm an architectural historian and an
off-road driving instructor what about
you that's very cool i work in tech for
an educational consultancy very nice i'm
jake i'm an executive and a personal
coach cool names my name is shalini and
i'm a mental health therapist
[Music]
[Music]
that's cool high five
[Music]
i like it too i'm always about that the
with laughter too is important of course
yeah
i didn't totally make that happen
because that's me
okay perfect
i like yours too i just never done this
sounds pretty
phenomenal arcade
something active followed by
okay yeah something to get the blood
flowing yeah arcade is cool too yeah i
love video games yeah
i love that so much
i dated music i'm ending with sunset
that's very nice i've been to one museum
and all the time i've lived in new york
why don't tell anyone
oh my god no i told everyone
that's not a problem for me
yeah that's kind of your job yeah
anger issues and being of type yeah you
kind of go hand in hand absolutely easy
going it's the way to go right yeah
okay yeah yeah
i mean that's a good deal breaker yeah
being i don't you know being nice just
to strangers is good i hope you don't
lie though no no i don't lie that's not
a lie
this was fun never experienced doing
something like this with a complete
stranger and i'm with you i thought this
was fun it's actually a cool way to get
to know somebody without you know
someone else prompting the questions um
at the end of the day sometimes the last
thing i want to do is go ask more
questions right so it's really nice to
give in the question and then need to
learn about you in this case right
through this i think that your
off-roading career thing is very cool
that's for sure
i'd love to hear more about that yeah
and take a course i can take you
off-roading that's something i can have
there we go let's do it we'll do it
right now
[Music]